Now let's see here, 10 raised to the 3rd power, that's 10x10x10. That's 1,000.
The square root of 4, well 2 times 2 is 4, so that's 2. The absolute value of 3
minus 5, that's the absolute value of minus 2. Absolute value takes away the
minus sign, and that's 2. Intuitively, what it means it's the magnitude of the
distance to go from 3 to 5. So you have to go two steps, you use the absolute
value, so that the direction doesn't matter. The absolute value of 5 minus 3 is
the same as the absolute value of 3 minus 5. It's just the distance between
these two values. Now, I've tossed in a couple of others just to see if you can
guess these. Min and max are the smaller and the larger of these arguments
here. So the miniumn of 300 and 255 is the smaller one, 255. The larger one of
zero and minus 1. Well, zero is pretty small, but it is larger than minus 2 so
that's zero. And our next image processing exercise will put min and max to
good use.